hi i'm kirby howe baptiste and i play
anita hi
i'm paul houser and i play horace hey
i'm uh joel fryer hey jasper hi i'm emma
stone and i play cruella devoe
we are the cast of disney's cruella and
we are here with buzzfeed
to take a quiz to find out which disney
villain we are
so let's begin shall we
first question first things first what
is your number one vice
a stiff cocktail caffeine video games
gossip social media or naps
i feel like i live in a few of these
spaces i'm gonna say a stiff cocktail
for sure i love
my old fashions and palomas and aviators
i'll go cocktail as well
i'm going to have caffeine i i i drink
more coffee than anyone i know
i'm going to go naps i wish i could nap
the way you do
oh i'm an incredible nappa i cannot
touch a
being able to sleep well is such a brag
it's
such a brag like all you do as a kid is
fight naps and then you
grow up and you're like i would give
anything
pick a famous dog for your loyal
sidekick
is it scooby-doo from scooby-doo bruiser
from legally blonde
snoopy from charlie brown toto from the
wizard of
oz clifford from clifford the big red
dog
max from the grinch what do you guys got
snoopy i'm like snippy snoopy doesn't do
much man i don't know if you've seen
snoopy he's pretty lazy
i guess i actually would go with
clifford because he's a big red dog
and he's it he's so cute i gotta go max
from the grinch because he's kind of got
the cute buddiness
of buddy the dog buddy the dog is my
favorite dog
pick a famous london landmark to explore
we have st james park harrods
big ben buckingham palace king's cross
station
or abbey road who's cross i gotta go
herons
i've been to herod's a few times and i
actually quite enjoyed it i
100 agree harrods the rest of these is
there's not that much to explore
although if you could explore buckingham
palace and walk through everything then
maybe i would choose that
this is a funny one for me because i
grew up really close to kings cross and
i've seen
kings cross what it is now what king's
cross used to be and you just did not go
to king's cross
people will know like king's cross 10 15
years ago was like
i'm with you and if we're saying
buckingham palace to go inside
that's the one i'm gonna make it inside
let's click it yeah as if
it's inside because then i would choose
that for sure which
british pop are you performing at
karaoke this is impossible
are you ready for this list wanna be by
the spice girls
don't stop me now by queen valerie by
amy winehouse
what makes you beautiful by one
direction should i stay or should i go
by the clash
or shut up by stormzy i'm gonna go with
queen don't stop me now
should i stay or should i go i'm going
wanna be by the spice girls i know
all the words already and it's so
annoying when you think you know a bit
of a song like i'm gonna pick that for
karaoke and you realize you only know
the chorus
yeah this one i know so wannabe i wanna
choose wannabe but i really think that
valerie is so much fun to sing
i'm gonna choose valerie but you can
sing right i can't sing
you can sing
i just love that story from a to z if
you want to get with me you better
listen carefully you know you've got m
in your face who likes in the place you
know got you with emcee who likes it on
an easy jeep
and as for me which villain do you think
deserves a second chance harley quinn
from the suicide squad
previously from the devil wears prada
draco malfoy from harry potter
joker from the dark knight killmonger
from black panther
or serci lannister from game of thrones
the joker i'm gonna say miranda
priestley from the devil worst product
because she's done the least
horrible stuff of all of these people i
think you know she's like she's cruel
and she makes people feel bad but she's
not like trying to kill
i'm gonna say joker too i love heath
ledger and i'll just
put him in with the joker and say wish
we had a second chance with heath
i'm gonna go kill monger because i
really thought he had a point he's one
of those like ambiguous villains to me
where it's like
i get it pick something black and white
a newspaper
a black and white cookie a domino a
yin-yang symbol
a piano or a zebra i would do a yin-yang
symbol
same i'm gonna say newspaper i kind of
miss the art of the newspaper
paul that's so poetic thank you i've
been waiting for people to discover me
finally pick something red all over
a red panda a tube of red lipstick
an apple a double decker bus a rose
or a trip to target trip to target yo
come on trip to target bury you
well it's a trip to target there's
basically a trip to asda oh right the
bus
there i'm going double decker bus as
well i'm going a rose
i got cruella deville no way
and it says you look good and you know
it it's
everywhere you go and because of the
energy you emit
and the clothes on your back you may do
a bad thing here and there but
no one will dare say you look bad while
doing it yes
i got hades and i feel good about it
that was the villain you wanted to be
i won't lie i'm salty about this i'm
probably going to retake it i got hades
from hercules
i don't feel like i know hercules well
enough to have been but maybe
i'm this villain okay call me what you
want but you can't call me boring
listen if someone is going to hell your
humorous and witty disposition
is all the more welcoming even if it's a
warm welcome to an eternity in the
underworld
i got the queen of hearts from alice in
wonderland that's so cool cool
my favorite disney you rule with an iron
fist
or rather an iron heart rational may not
be a word in your vocabulary that's
actually true but all rationale goes out
the window when you're as passionate as
you are i'm into it
thank you so much buzzfeed we had a
blast doing that crazy quiz
we can't wait for the film on may 28th
in theaters or on disney plus with
premier access to be honest the the real
disney villain is
warner media and netflix
i feel like warner media
you